foreign
[Music]
you can't pick and choose what you like
whatever I showed you and I say for
example is worshiping Allah in his
powers and everything that he does
singling out Allah in worship His names
and attributes when we go to the
scriptures and if I prove to you my
scripture is correct you can't see
because and same with you same with you
yeah because I know your name
but let me just explain something to you
right yeah what comes out from talking
to you yes go ahead is it you were
talking about how how come it came later
and not at the beginning but in a way
many Muslims are kind of making a very
similar argument that and it may be that
you say oh no no that's not true but
it's another way but it's very similar
argument that the truth came with the
prophet Muhammad because everybody else
was corrupted
it's very simple that's my argument no
it's not because you said all the
scriptures got corrupted but they had
the truth can I tell you we hold on
because at the beginning of the grand
subject because you seem to have read a
journey right that's at the beginning
yeah you might have heard the other word
such means truth which is at the
beginning at the beginning God is such
and then
at the beginning of time and then at the
time when time started then security was
also true and then now is true and
forever it will be true
no no what was he believes that the sick
view was true from the beginning only
thing is some people did have access to
that truth for example I'll give you an
example of a guy that found the truth
his name was
Sufi yeah unfortunately he stood up one
day opened up his jacket and he goes and
he blow himself up no no no no he goes I
am one of the truth I am the truth he
didn't get blown up he got killed in a
very terrible way by the Islamic uh
terrorists at that time they killed him
okay chopped him into pieces for saying
that he is the truth he was saying
so this way has been around in every way
okay it's not that we're saying that
we're the only ones that found it
are you saying why did the truth if it
was there from the beginning why did it
come like uh 1600 years ago as a Quran
is that what you say because I said that
earlier you said you said scriptures
we believe in
Islam has been there from day one not
with what you believe it
okay you don't believe me I'm telling
you what I'm gonna tell you to believe
that yeah so what I'm trying to say is
Islam has been there from day one that's
why when we say Jesus this was a Muslim
the Christians get confused what do you
mean it was a Muslim that you're not
understanding what I mean the one who
submissions
because Jesus says
he says
in the scripture
yeah I I don't say nothing about myself
as I hear
okay please so Jesus was a Muslim so
what we say is God Almighty existed he
sent down prophets yes and with some of
the prophets and Messengers he gave them
scriptures right those scriptures were
not were meant for those people at that
time all right so what happened is once
a scripture came they would prophesy
that's not nice the time is important
have some reasons he learned from the
brothers yeah unfortunately carefully
anyway sorry so what I'm trying I'm
sorry forgive me so the Prophet come the
messenger comes with the scripture
very old time for those specific times
because if God Almighty finished in his
plan those other projects that were
going to come and the Mysteries wouldn't
come so for example with the Old
Testament the Old Testament was given to
uh Moses with the Ten Commandments Etc
and he was prophesied up another Prophet
that will come not only Jesus but
Muhammad as well all right so what
happened
maybe you've seen it but other people
love it yeah so when those scriptures
came down it wasn't meant to be
preserved he talked about another
prophet come Jesus came the ones who
follow the scriptures correctly said
this is the one that was prophesied we
follow him then then you had people who
followed Jesus and Jesus says I have
many things to say unto you but you
cannot bear them now
okay then it talked about the prophet
Muhammad the Quran is the only scripture
where God Almighty said that final
Messengers come we have the Old
Testament the New Testament and the
final test today so the Quran is the
seal that says everything's obviously
Ali you know that I don't agree with you
no I know
that's why I'm seeing it because you're
arguing back and forth let's go to your
scriptures and my scriptures if not if
your scripture is true or may this
accept and follow you no problem I am
ready to do it right now if my
scriptures is true and I have evidence
based on that you can't be confused
here's the thing and you know there's a
beautiful thing I read in the teacher
yes
the the actual in the later time how you
would actually say it yeah he said that
the truth is more the guru the truth is
more beloved to me than religion or
something no that was a made-up quote is
Jesus
[Music]
that says that the highest thing of all
this Truth for higher than truth is
truth for living living by the truth
yeah that's higher than just believing
the truth okay but okay so hey hey
the reason why this argument again like
what you said anything is going to go
nowhere is that even if I you can see
Guru against you online I don't have to
show you so you can shoot it yourself
it's already available online you can
read the scripture yeah and if it
appeals to you right if it doesn't
appeal to you
there is no compulsion of religion but I
have to convey the message
I've read the Quran yeah and I've also
heard a lot of speeches by Muslim
Scholars yes and the thing is is for me
yeah it doesn't fulfill the requirements
of truth but who gives you the criteria
okay
all that time with
because I believe if there is a Creator
if the creator has sent down a scripture
this scripture should not be altered
with it should not be changed okay okay
so this is good so I believe the same
with the Quran so we need to put our
scriptures to the test yeah
no okay then okay if you believe Allah
says in the Quran if this book was not
other than from your lord you will find
many descriptions and contradictions in
it I challenge you to find me a single
contradiction a single error in the
Quran that has been changed
I'm gonna listen to you because let's
listen to the brothers well yeah okay
the second one is Allah says in the
Quran that he challenges the
disbelievers and says bring a chapter
like you like if you think this will
forgottoma it's good it's like me coming
and saying I will knock out anyone here
so and if I go if he says boom I knock
him out so so then bring him yeah
speak look speak the truth even if it's
against yourself if you bring me
evidence if I'm truthful and I'm looking
for the truth I'm on camera I will leave
Islam this is how certain I am all right
so I'm saying bring it I'm ready to
drink what would happen one day I asked
you one day we're still living in uh
Pakistan the whole village is Muslim and
everybody in the most in the village at
night has a realization of who they were
in their past life just have a theory
it's a theoretical argument okay
everybody suddenly realized who they
were in their past life okay right and
they all really important
let's just imagine they had happened
right yeah so at that moment effectively
they'd have to leave Islam according to
what so let's say they now believe that
was true
but let's say they decided yeah oh it's
true yeah
many people in this world have actually
experienced their past life right okay
there's no there's also a confirmation
by itself the confirmation bias exists
as well yeah that somebody who's not
going to believe something it doesn't
matter what happens
a lot of people believe in reincarnation
we're talking about your scriptures
and I'll tell you the difference between
our argument and your argument just in
one sentence yeah I'm going in one
sentence the main difference is that we
aim to offer proves and evidences but as
you're saying just believe yeah and
that's that miracle
100 coaches right I've trained these
hundred people for five years yeah okay
and one guy comes along and trains one
guy right for one more year and that guy
becomes faster than everybody else in
that whole group okay so the group turns
to that one guy and said how did you
become so fast because because of that
guy the trainer yeah so then what is
what will make those people are 100
people being logical wanting to win see
that guy go ahead they might say you
know what I want to go and try but that
guy's training okay let me try Okay let
me try the training yes they become
faster okay right yeah now they all
believe in this guy now
from the very beginning Okay the reason
for us believing in our Guru is because
not does he only give the most Sublime
truths with the best that's objective
but when he tells us to follow it and it
works we experience God in the way that
he's describing okay and it's so
mind-blowing okay
it's only subjective
[Music]
I'll leave it to you you say what you're
like I'm not gonna say anything about it
30 seconds sorry what was your last
sentence sorry it says that uh that's
the answer you're telling me from Guru
did you ever hear me like for example
that I gave you the Quran the scripture
I can come to the prophet in his life
that's another evidence I came to you
from the scripture
okay
okay if he's the scripture
you need to bring me evidence because
you're telling me because he
came and he made more and the truth
seems more with him that's why I'm
telling you look the Christians come and
say to me you know there's a Christian
who came to and he goes Jesus speak to
my ticket to go holiday I'm looking at
him and I'm like are you okay he truly
believes in it but it's subjective it's
subjective if I said to you I accepted
the stand if I said I accepted Islam
because it changed my life it's
subjective I'm going to the scripture
because you will come and say to me look
I'm gonna change my life
okay
are you here next week are you here next
week brother
no
[Music]
foreign